en es où pourquoi tu as besoin d'aide
j'ai été
débarqué m fait gentiment comprendre que
l'affaire était trop grosse pour moi
alors j'ai tout naturellement pensé à
Toine que tu me fasses chier j'a pas
mais que tu les emmerdes ça alors j'ai
de informations pour
toi d'abord on a trouvé le journal
intime de G dans son appart
il y a des pages qu'il faut éviter genre
pervers éta pas
mal chose de plus intéressant je viens
de recevoir les analysesem de
chaussures justement c'est pas des
baskets LE spécialiste c'est des copies
de chaussures de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale tu fait chier autant que tu
m'as fait chier bien faire de mon
mieux